de trop permet de
d'avoir une récupération plus rapide
pour le cheval en fait tout simplement
ça évite les courbatures le lendemain à
éliminer tous
alors c'est quoi maintenant l'objectif
gagner tour est gagné bien joué 17 un
monde déchiré par ce qu on a fait pas
mal de déchet c'est moi les déchets bah
c'est à dire on a raté pas mal de buts
on a fait moi j'étais comme une fois
qu'on a pas après on a raté pas mal de
buts on ne rate pas mal de choses donc
c'est d'améliorer tout pour que dimanche
au vote
c'est très complet vous vraiment moi
c'est vraiment le collectif et la
rapidité que je peux aller le lien qu'on
peut avoir avec le cheval et apparaître
que des couples en fait vraiment trouvé
son cheval pour faire vraiment un couple
est vraiment quelqu'un et en poids le
lien les différents pour ce sport que
non la chaîne on doit leur faire
complètement confiance c'est très
important qu'on garde
je fais pas qui rendent un gars plein
d'autres qui prennent le chemin du but
et qui emmène en fait là
allez sans avoir les mains soient là
encore s'être bien des fois le touche au
sport
j'arrive pas alors la partie anticipé
mais ça commence à venir que du temps du
temps non pas pour s'apprivoiser mais
tout simplement toutes les réactions et
exactement quand elle voit risée
j'ai tricoté ta copine